[Music]
good to see you guys again oh hello mr.
Whiteface I mean you no harm so please
don't come at me that's a conversation I
had with a kitty cat several days ago
it's also now the slogan for Black
History Month I have a cousin that's
very sensitive when it comes to racial
issues he called me recently because he
was quiet upset that he went to a tuba
recital where he was one of only three
black tuba players and he thought that
was racist and I wanted to agree but
then I realized three black tuba players
is a lot of black
in fact if you see more than five black
tuba players
you're watching an Outkast video I saw a
horrible thing recently I saw a
gentleman on the bus with a tattoo on
his neck that just read Linda that guy
hates Linda or he has to remind himself
to be intimate with Linda either way
Linda could do better
oh you guys know Linda oh you like that
good now used to a 300-pound black man
that giggles like a asian schoolgirl I'm
not a tough person I don't understand it
when people act tough you act tough that
just tells me you've been through a lot
of horrible things and you survived them
and now you're ready to attack anyone
anytime like a pit bull
I want a demeanor that says I've never
been through anything at all and I'm
just a pug right in a decorative pillow
I bought my son a cat recently you might
know him as mr. Whiteface
got them from the Humane Society which
may have been a mistake as most of their
cats are defective
I found this out when I went to buy one
they said you can get this cat but we're
99% sure he's deaf or he's just a cat
found out horrible news while I was
there cuz they force you to read
brochures did you know that 40% of all
North American cats are obese I don't
know why you would chuckle that - I'll
repeat it so you understand the gravity
of this situation
40% of all North American cats are obese
which is only great news if you love fat
here skittles